is brady really gone because now there's
a rumor he's going to come back
and go back to new england the rumor is
he'd go back and sign
a contract for one day and get retired
as a
patriot to go back and play
no no that that's not going to happen
now the only one who can really find out
what tom's future is is you
you're right
the the
the best the best brady interviews are
you and tom and i used to talk about you
all the time when we would do a new
england game and he was living like in
the back bay in the boston in boston and
he would drive down to foxborough half
an hour he listened to you every morning
and we would you know communicate from
time to time hear howard this morning
and then your interviews with uh with
brady were were fantastic and every
every journalist in the country was
jealous
he is the greatest of all time though
right i mean there's no doubt i mean i
don't know you know but i i mean this
guy's career what a career and by the
way i still think again i don't know you
know more than me
i think he could do another season i
mean he had a terrific season he he he
could
i mean look he led the league in
touchdown passes this season he set a
record nfl record most completions in
the season he got his team he brought
him back from a 27-3 deficit and almost
won the game in against the rams and
they would have put them in the in the
championship game
he had a fabulous year um
i don't know i i began to since we did
that game i had him in the meeting
before the game and i said
do you think about a perfect ending
and he said he hesitated he said
it would include a super bowl but i'm
not sure it's just here and then he kind
of went back and forth and i said on the
on the air when we were talking about
that conversation we had i said tom was
talking in switchbacks
here and there and back and forth
so chris and i
felt even though we didn't know for sure
that it was more likely that he would
retire than not retire but there's no
question the way he played this year of
course he could have played next year
robert craft the owner of new england
patriots was upset they report
that when brady said um i'm leaving he
didn't mention the new england patriots
and and bob craig was really upset by
that
i would imagine brady's kind of pissed
at the new england patriots seeing the
kind of uh football he's still playing
they should have kept him for another
one or two years i think that was easy
to say but you know that's a 20 years he
was there for 20 years that's a long
time and maybe you begin to look at
what else is out there i know one thing
that tom loved is the fact that he was
able to go to a southern team
practice in december outside because you
know how hard it is to practice in
foxborough in november and december i've
been out there a bunch of times at their
practices do you think he'll start
broadcasting
i think he will at some point i'm not
sure he will do that sooner than later i
think he may take a little bit of time
right now to do whatever he wants to do
what's your sense would he be any good
at it
yes
yeah i mean he's really smart yeah tom
is smart and and again he'd be the kind
of guy
like peyton manning
manny would be terrific at this thing
because peyton peyton absorbs things
gets things understands it uh knows what
the forensics are all about there are
guys who are in the ex shock business
and guys who are in the broadcasting
business you got to think of yourself in
the in the broadcasting and
communications business
peyton understands that brady will
definitely understand that